so there's this article that got
forwarded to me title is 38-year-old
woman decides she wants a baby claims
she's been betrayed by feminism all
right um I like this so this is a story
that I've that I've heard a lot of over
the last few years you know before I
read this just want to have quick quick
preface to it we've seen this over and
over and over and over again right so
Zoe and Luna they were talking earlier
on about prioritizing career uh Luna
wants to go to Prague and you know work
over there for a period of time there's
a guy that she's hot for zoee you know
also wants to prioritize you know the
career and I'm asking questions about
you know have you thought up about these
things or contemplating you know some of
these ideas about a potential future
because a lot of women now you'll you'll
start to see articles it's usually like
late 30s um that they start to talk
about this maybe into the early 40s if
they haven't had their kids
yet so 38-year-old woman decides she
wants a baby uh it reads a woman said
she felt betrayed by feminism after
deciding she wanted to settle down have
a family and a husband as she approached
her 39th birthday at one point now guys
if you're watching women's ability to
have children decreases over the years
like their peak fertilities in their
very early 20s every year after that the
chances of a high-risk pregnancy
increase year after year by the time
they hit 40 it's it's not a good idea
generally speaking right uh so this girl
Melissa purling recently wrote an essay
for Business Insider titled I'm 38 in
signal I recently realized I wanted a
child I'm terrified I've missed the
opportunity she said it went viral in no
in sorry in November hate began to pour
in from men telling her that she's lived
a selfish life uh personing has much has
a much different account of her story so
people are telling her you know you've
been selfish and you've missed the boat
and she say no I have a different
account when she was 22 she married a
traditional man and moved to a rural
community in Idaho uh this is where she
grew up she wanted a simple life with
children sorry he wanted a simple life
with children and homecook meals she
said however personally despite coming
from a religious Christian background
made it clear to her husband to be that
she did not want children at that time I
felt very strongly I did not want
children I wasn't going to be like a
traditional housewife I knew that I
wanted to pursue a career sound familiar
Zoe 100% yes it does she told Fox News
digital in an interview and I felt very
strongly that would never change and I
guess I was wrong personing said both
her and her ex thought that love could
conquer everything but after 10 years it
was clear that their differences and
life goals were irreconcilable personing
says she came she became resentful when
he would ask for a dinner or for his
laundry to be done shocking you know
that a man would ask for something you
know that women would typically have
done for thousands of years like a pink
job right whereas I'm sure she had the
expectation of him that he would cut the
grass shovel the driveway change the
tires from Summer to Winters and stuff
like that uh so she became resentful
when he would ask for simple task like
laundry or a dinner uh I did little to
hide my disdain for our small town life
he was a good and hardworking man but I
don't think I made him feel that way at
30 ping and her ex divorced she swore
off the idea of marriage this is her
crying here on the television interview
uh when she's come to the realization
the terror of wanting to be married at
38 and have children when she left it
for too long I told my friends and
family I'd never get married again I
needed Independence this is at 30 again
a fulfilling career and a space to chart
my own course does any of this sound
familiar Zoe
yeah and I didn't think marriage fit
into that Vision marriage relationship
you know you can substitute marriage for
dating relationship whatever I was
content to look forward to future
without a husband children and the
trappings of a traditional life she
wrote as she Grew Older however the fun
the Carefree lifestyle being whne and
dine going to parties began to get old
the pursuit of comfort and self became
dull she said when she turned 38 Terror
be Terror began to take over I was panic
tricking I really thought I was going to
die alone it scared me I almost wrote uh
the article as sort of a warning to
other women I don't want people to miss
out on the importance of things in life
because they've just enjoyed themselves
and because I don't think that's ever
going to be sorry ever really going to
make you happy she said again another
screenshot of her I'll you know bust it
up over the conversation with Fox Media
uh she wrote in the article how she felt
urgency to find a stable relationship
and was rethinking about wanting
marriage and children at 38
I hardly recognized myself she wrote in
the article I also began to feel selfish
for spending so much time focusing
solely on myself my very existence
started to feel shallow and Hollow and
retrospect personally believed uh she
had some self-discovery to to do to work
on it took time sort of through previous
trauma her parents divorce which she
described as coming from a broken home
sound familiar
Zoe took time to heal blah blah blah I
grew up in a fairly traditional family
but my family but my parents were
divorced and I would say that probably
had some effect on the feelings about
having family coming from a broken home
certainly has its hardship she told uh
at one point she recalled a man coming
over to her in a coffee store okay she's
just sort of we uh okay so this is the
guys that that you know she's kept in
the friend zone now uh and then a happy
per turn to personing story arrived when
she describes the exception as not the
rule for women in her age group shortly
after Penning the article she dated a
man who she previously befriended dates
a guy puts him in the friend zone
they're already talking about marriage
and a future she dished out the details
so it's a guy that I've been friends
with guy that I've been friends with uh
and we've always just sort of stayed in
touch so for those watching that are men
you need to understand that women like
to have a backup plan uh it could be a
gay dude could be a guy that she put in
the friend zone that she's not totally
attractive to but sees him as maybe
husband material because he's successful
but he's not attracted enough for her to
Pine for him sort of thing it's it's
pretty common for guys to end up in that
zone hoping that if they're a nice
enough guy at some point she'll see his
virtues in the future and want to you
know settle for him or to you know go
for him sort of thing these are the guys
who make deals that if we're both single
at 30 if we're both single at 40 if
we're both single at 40 or 38 let's
let's get married and have a baby
right and then it and then it goes on to
say after her epip
by the way women hit a Epiphany phase in
their late 20s early 30s where they're
like I think it's time to have babies uh
she wanted a traditional life shocking
right in her 20s she wanted to pursue a
career and uh establish herself which is
unsurprising because if you come from a
single parent household you see how that
parent struggles the parent often tells
the child don't rely on anybody you know
build your own life build your own path
make sure you've got a secure income uh
man you know like a woman needs a man
like a fish needs a bicycle a lot of
these you know sort of sound bites so
she went from not wanting a traditional
life in her 20s to wanting one in her
30s and it hit her like a ton of bricks
this guy is the one that God's been
preparing me for this is also usually
when they find God too by the way I've
had these relationships since there were
so many butterflies and so many like oh
my gosh checking my phone did he text
and I realized that's not love that's
not anxiety actually let me read that
again when a woman's thinking oh my gosh
checking my phone did he text she's
right it's not love and it's not anxiety
it's lust for somebody it's it it
translates into genuine burning desire
your phone alert goes off and you wonder
yourself is it him but it's not it's
somebody else it's neither love nor
anxiety it's Lust For That guy that's
what genuine burning desire looks like
from a woman is you know she's she's
stoked when her alert goes off and it's
him she'll skip every other message
leave guys on red that she's not
interested to but if that guy messages
boom wants to see it immediately um
never knew where I stood with these
people again see this is the thing right
you know the whole I never knew where I
stood with these people if women aren't
finding Clarity in where they stand
easily as they expect it to be then
they'll then they'll just not respond to
him you know like Zoe's story where the
guy snapchated him that night later on
after the nightclub and she didn't
respond it's that thinking like I don't
know where I stand like you know what's
he's about why did he behave strangely
I'm just going to ignore him for a
couple of days because that's what I've
always been told right if the guy
doesn't fall in line and give me what I
want all the time but the thing that
women forget is that a lot of these guys
again they're in demand there's a lot of
very attractive beautiful women that are
in their orbit that want to spend time
with them so they're going to be busy
you know and and it's going to be
incumbent on women to some degree to do
a little bit of the pursuing in that
type type of situation but again you
know I never knew where I stand with
these guys that I had genuine burning
desire for so now she has to settle for
this beta mail she has to settle for the
guy that you know sat in her orbit for
years in the friend zone probably
listened to stories about how she was
going out with a dude named Chad that
didn't you know want to commit to her or
you know take her on a proper date he
just wants to be an FWB and you know
user and uh you know call her over at
his convenience this this is the sort of
thing that I see a lot of a lot of Zoe
what do you think about that well okay
so I'm not going to lie I've mentioned
that to my mom I'm like oh my gosh like
I was in a relationship for five years
and it took me this long to realize I
didn't want to be with him could you
imagine if I were to find somewhere
tomorrow like you know someone tomorrow
and I'm with this man for three four
five years and I'm what 28 around that
time and I have to start all over again
and then I'm like wait that kind of
scared sces me because should I settle
down now should I wait should I travel
cuz you know what I mean like I want to
be able to take this time to travel and
like be single but then a part of me is
like will I be too late to have kids but
my mom had me around
36 so she's always like you can always
wait like you you always will have time
like and if it's meant to be it's meant
to be and like that's kind of my opinion
about it like I still want to be able to
travel and like not settle down like
where I live right now I still want to
be able to experience that right but I
mean you've also seen a lot of these um
like you were telling some stories
earlier about some of these successful
guys with their you know wives and
children on the boats in the weekend you
know having a good time traveling it's
it's plausible to do that as well as a
family right I mean so I agree your mom
was 36 when she had you do you have any
other siblings I have a sister um she
has been in a long-term relationship and
she just moved in with him MH and your
sister's older or younger uh she's one
year older than me okay and same
father uh yes okay and what does your
dad say about everything in life today
when you go to him for advice
unfortunately I have not met my father
um my mom's been single since you know
since I was born so so you didn't have
any access to your dad when you were
growing up no so what happened there um
he got into drugs and alcohol and was
arrested and he was in jail
my entire life so I never really got to
meet him so I mean you're going to have
to take this with a grain of salt but I
dispense cold heart truth bomb so your
mom made a your mom made a really bad
choice in choosing your
father yeah she chose an awful guy you
know as an example of a father and a man
and she's giving you advice on when to
have
kids um I think it's just her kind of
supporting like how I feel about you
know pursuing my career and you know
wanting to travel because she you know
she was able to travel because she was a
flight attendant her entire career and
so I think that's just a dream of mine I
feel like she just wants to support my
dream it's not necessarily her putting
in her opinion about when I should have
kids ever like she would never if I
found a you know she would support me if
I were to find a man tomorrow you
know I think I think what we're trying
to drive at Zoe and I had a question I
was gonna I'm G to Pivot to this
so understandably your mom wants you to
be happy she wants to support you she's
coming from a good place as most family
members generally are I think what
sometimes can be danger I don't know if
dangerous is the right word but I think
that the benefit of kind of a show like
this and talking about talking to two
guys that you know don't necessarily
have much of a stake in in your future
and you're just having a conversation is
that often times our our friends and our
family are some of the most likely folks
to not give it to us straight to protect
us from bad things that might happen um
and so I think it's a struggle your
story specifically and I think for a lot
of women growing up and and you know
especially for women that are growing up
without sort of a and I was going to ask
about this but was there any sort of
sort of positive male influence in your
life that was it a uncle or a c or
anybody a family friend that you sort of
looked at as sort of the beacon for
masculinity or has it always just been
your mom and sister um I did have a
really positive influence on my uncle he
lives in Virginia and he just flew down
from my graduation with his uh with my
aunt um they have a beautiful son and I
look at them as you know relationship
goals for sure yeah yeah I'd be I'd be
interested if you were to have that
conversation with them what kind of
advice they would give you
I think especially if you're looking at
the people that you want to embody and
and asking the people you know we kind
of have a saying and rich is as a part
of this on me as a kind of student of of
you know his teachings and some other
things is
yeah make sure the people that you're
taking advice from or the people that
you would want to trade places with
right or if you see people that are
embodying and having the life that you
want to have they're probably pretty
good you know Role Models or or pretty
good people to ask about their kind of
advice and what you kind of think what
they think you should sort of do even if
they are family I think one of the
things we try to drive at
is the this woman in this article and I
think your mother especially having two
kids post 35 and this woman having a kid
maybe she's gonna have a kid 30 or 40
are not necessarily the norm but they're
generally exceptions to the rule and I
think the one thing we just always want
people to sort of be mindful of is that
I think the biggest lie that most women
are told today is that you can can have
everything you want and you'll never
miss out you can travel the world you
can be single you can make all the money
you want you can go to a beautiful
exotic places you can also find the man
of your dreams pop out a bunch of kids
be it stay a whole mom and the reality
is the most unhappy demographic of
people in this country are single
unmarried women with no children over
the age of 40 um so this is kind of like
our this is sort of my un unsolicited
advice segment but um I I would have a
conversation with with the Virginia
folks and shout out to Virginia that's
where I'm from originally but um I would
have a I would have a conversation with
those folks and and get their honest
opinion and kind of figure out what they
did to make it work and and take it for
some people that you would that embody
the life that you want to have and and
kind of get an idea of what they have to
say I really hope you guys enjoyed that
clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clip's from if you're newer to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out